hey guys hey guys
welcome back to the channel if you're
new here my name is tammy and i'm an
architect in beautiful vancouver bc so
in this video i'm going to share with
you the system that i use to organize my
life
and keep a fairly stress-free existence
this video is sponsored by hellofresh
stay till the end of the video to see
how you can get some free delicious
meals i work full time as an architect
and just about two years ago i started
this youtube channel which has turned
into
an almost full-time job in order to keep
myself organized and sane
i've had to adopt a pretty efficient
workflow i use a combination of sensama
and google calendar and i'll give you
guys a general overview of how i use
them but also talk about my personal
philosophy on productivity that
hopefully you can apply into your own
system whatever that is you can find the
links to the apps and also some reading
references that's really helped me
define my philosophy on productivity
down in the description so there's two
really important ideas that kind of set
the foundation for how i organize my
time and i guess you could call them my
work philosophy so the first idea is i
try to give priority to deep work and i
try to build this into my routine as a
non-negotiable because i realize that if
i don't do this it never really happens
i talk about the idea of deep work in my
book review i'll leave it right here but
in essence deep work is work that
requires quite a bit of focus and is
typically like two or three hours long
and then the second idea it's doing
things in a flow state so first of all i
do this by making sure that everything
that i need to do and want to do and all
the ideas that i have is captured on a
system that i trust and by doing this i
can make sure that i'm not thinking
about another idea or a task that i have
to do when i'm already doing something
secondly i try to minimize switch
between different types of tasks i try
to group similar tasks together as much
as possible i'll show you how these
ideas kind of actually manifest in my
schedule a little bit later on so like i
said my deep work sessions are just
built into my routine and these are
things that i don't even really have to
think about doing they're just a fact of
life for me
so you can see this in my calendar um
everything that's routine is in yellow
and yeah that's things like my deep work
sessions my daily review or gym
and my calendar sinks directly into
sensama
which is kind of my home for everything
another side to setting up your routines
is kind of understanding your peak times
we only have five hours in a day when we
can concentrate really hard so we really
need to use this time wisely so for me
that's right in the mornings it's also
when i have the least amount of
distractions but yours might be
different if you don't know when your
peak times are i would just start off by
tracking your days over a period of like
two or three weeks just try to get a
sense of when you're the most productive
so these routines kind of set the
foundation for my weekly schedule
and
it also helps me
not have to spend so much time
actually like planning these things
when it comes to actually scheduling my
weeks i dedicate about an hour every
sunday just to
roughly planning out my week and you can
see that that's also scheduled in my
calendar and so
first of all i try to set like three
goals for the week in the objectives tab
if i finish these three things
i can go out for a beer on friday and
just feel accomplished i also have it in
my calendar to check in every day to see
if i'm on track these little planning
sessions on sunday and throughout the
week is also when i do what i call a
brain dump
our brains are great at
many things
but
it's not so great at remembering things
or keeping track of things
or at least mine isn't and so if i don't
put it down somewhere i'm gonna be
constantly worried that i'm forgetting
something it's really taking up the
limited brain power that i have so every
sunday i try to dump everything that's
on my mind that alone just gives me a
peace of mind then throughout the week
like whenever something pops into my
head i put it down in the same place i
use a combination of sensama and click
up but it can be anything it can be a
notebook or an app but just make sure
that it's something that you actually
like using
because you will have to refer back to
it regularly if you want it to work
after i do my brain dump on my sunday
planning sessions i move into the
processing stage
sometimes when you're just dumping ideas
from your brain and you're just like
trying to capture your thoughts they're
not totally fleshed out into actionable
tasks so i dedicate time during my
sunday planning sessions or at the end
of each day
to just like quickly process them into
concrete actionable tasks
and then actually schedule them into my
calendar if there's anything that's
urgent and you know if there's anything
that can be done in less than two
minutes i just do it without actually
scheduling it into my calendar that way
you can just kind of move on and knock
these down pretty quickly you can
actually put in an estimated time for
each task as well so you can pretty
quickly see if your workload is
realistic or not it integrates with your
calendar so for example my morning deep
work sessions you can see that it's
blocked out you can also link your gmail
to this and turn them into tasks
sometimes you have an email where you
need to respond with like a little bit
more information for example if you're
putting together like a fee proposal
it's gonna take you a little bit more
time to work through that yeah just like
schedule that email as a task here and
drag and drop that into your day i try
to dedicate a chunk of time to just
doing emails you know this is what i
mean by limiting context switching like
i try to chunk similar tasks in one
chunk of time so if i had to make like
five phone calls unless they're like
super super urgent i try to chunk them
all together in one part of my day email
especially is one of those super
dangerous time suckers
so i found that setting aside time for
them it really helps on days when i'm
more precise about what i'm gonna do
and when i'm gonna do it i have a way
more realistic expectation in my day and
it actually helps me feel more satisfied
at the end of the day and having a
roadmap really helps me get more things
done
reviewing your system regularly is the
only way to make improvements because
it's gonna give you a clear picture of
how you're spending your time and what's
working and what's not if you're feeling
too tired every single day
this is typically a good place for you
to go and you know see where your time
is being spent and what you can adjust
moving forward for me because my life is
divided into very distinct segments like
my job my youtube my personal life it's
really important and also interesting
for me to see how many hours i'm
spending in each category and you can do
that by going to your weekly review tab
which spits out this beautiful graph and
you can also turn on and off different
categories but
maintaining this can be really time
consuming and it is really easy to skip
this step but sensama actually has a
weekly and daily review prompt so i
found that really helpful but if you're
using a different system that doesn't
have this prompt i would just schedule
it in my calendar because this step is
quite important as you're doing your
review if there's anything that wasn't
completed you could move them into
different days by just doing drag and
drop
or you can archive them if you don't
need to do it this week what's nice
about this is it kind of creates these
automatic daily reports
so you can share them with other people
if you work in a team personally i just
started doing this for myself just so
that i have a record of what i'm getting
done throughout the week and it also
comes in handy when i'm doing a check-in
with my team at the beginning of the
week the most important thing to seeing
a tangible result is to make it a habit
i always try to keep since i'm open on
one of the windows so that i can
constantly have access to it managing
time is an actual skill and takes
practice so don't be too hard on
yourself in the beginning i think a
really big part of this is just
understanding how long things actually
take and just being realistic about your
expectations and the other side is when
you start to realize
okay like i can only do this this and
this you naturally start to set
priorities and just like dump things
that don't really matter for you since
zama does have a feature that
automatically puts tasks you haven't
done in a while in a backlog or an
archive or you can put them manually in
the archive folder as well the end goal
of all of this is to
have more free time so that you can
enjoy your life and have fun so
make sure that you're not just doing and
doing and doing and that you're actually
reflecting on what you're doing and also
remember to schedule in your leisure
time as a routine because that can also
be very hard to keep up since sama lets
you set a time limit for each day and
it's gonna give you an alert if you have
an unrealistic workload
and i have gotten this notification more
than a few times
productivity equals output over input
this means
you could increase your output to
increase productivity but you can also
decrease input by having a system that
does things for you this is a system
that i've developed over the years but
it is still evolving i hope it was
helpful for you in some way let me know
if you have any questions or if you want
me to do more of a deep dive into the
different functions on sensama there's a
free trial link in the description if
you want to check it out for yourself by
the way i have a lot of cool videos
about creativity and architecture like
the one where i talk about slow reading
and how it can change your brain click
here if you want to see more and don't
forget to gently click your mouse on the
bell
like and subscribe button i also have a
monthly newsletter if you want to keep
up to date on some of the different
things that are happening on the channel
before we end i want to share a quick
message from our sponsor so i've been
trying not to eat out as much because it
gets really expensive and it's bad for
your health because you don't really
know what they're putting in your food
but when you're working full time while
running a youtube channel the amount of
time that i can dedicate to culinary
explorations has been reduced to this
hellofresh provides step-by-step recipes
that are super easy to follow
with fresh pre-portioned ingredients to
help you reduce prep time every week i
can choose my meals from a collection of
delicious and well curated recipes the
recipes feature ingredients that go from
the farm to your front door in under a
week which means their spring menu
features the season's freshest flavors
you can choose veggie pescetarian or fit
and wholesome meals to make it easy for
you to stick to your goals hellofresh is
also really sensitive about the
environment
their meal kit cuts down on your food
waste by at least 25
compared to grocery shopping and in fact
hello fresh is the first carbon neutral
meal kit company and almost all their
packaging is recyclable go to
hellofresh.com and use codedammylee16
for up to 16 free meals and 3 surprise
gifts and with that i'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]
you